and now at hip-hop news break with Chuck
Taylor been a very busy day in the news
a lot of things have happened a Staten
Island man is listed in stable condition
tonight after a brutal assault by rapper
Method Man following an argument the
victim addressed the press earlier today
it was torture straight towards his son
first he put my nuts on the dresser
it was crazy just my nuts and then he
banged him with a spike fat super
handsome she kept feed and feed me baby
this all took place in slums of Shaolin
it was the RZA the GZA old Dirty Bastard
Raekwon the chef u-god Inspectah deck
and of course Method Man victim also
said that at one point during the
altercation Method Man put a hanger on
the stove and left it for like 40
minutes and then he stuck it in his ass
real slow
at this point Method Man is still at
large so stay tuned in News Channel 3
for this and other stories
[Applause]